this for me is one of the defining
moments in the development of an agenda
which I believe is essential for our
economy for jobs of the future for our
environment for sustainability on all
levels I'm absolutely convinced that the
circular economy if designed right can
enable a triple win there are economic
gains to be made from using raw
materials and resources more efficiently
and being less dependent on input there
are environmental gains from moving away
from linear economy where we throw away
her ducks that could be repaired or
recycled and there are social gains to
be made from preventing waste and reused
services good sorting of waste good
waste management and the right
infrastructure are essential to allow
good quality and low cost recycled
materials to be used by our economy a
new circular economy pocket will boost
recycling and resource efficiency foster
new markets for secondary world
materials and of course this should
create new business opportunities for
eco industries I passionately believe in
the opportunities of the circular
economy the main reason is this the
future is not in low cost production in
making things with finites
components the future is providing
services that then materialize in
products instead of the other way around
and products that are used and reused
time and time again in the waste sector
alone implementing existing legislation
by 2020 will create over 400,000 new
jobs and an increase in the annual
turnover of the waste sector by over 4.2
billion-euro implementing higher
recycling targets would create another
20,000 additional jobs the circular
economy can help Europe regain
competitiveness and ensure that we are
frontrunners in providing
environmentally and economically
sustainable solutions this requires both
regulatory certainty and investments for
the future
you